the 40-year manhunt for one of the most
prolific serial criminals in American
history perhaps coming to an end at this
suburban hall we found the needle in the
haystack and it was right here in
Sacramento police say this man 72
year-old Joseph James D'Angelo is the
elusive Golden State killer the former
police officer allegedly responsible for
at least 12 murders upwards of 50 rapes
and more than a hundred burglaries in
California from 1976 to 1986
D'Angelo's name never coming up in Prior
investigations but just six days ago a
critical clue we started some
surveillance we were able to get some
discarded DNA and we were able to
confirm what we thought we already knew
that we had our man there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hey everybody its episode 89
that's right
guess what day CAUTI the original Night
Stalker otherwise known as the Golden
State killer yep so we're gonna revisit
this subject because this is one of our
our first video on the original Night
Stalker is probably one of our most
popular shows yes I think it's got what
almost 18,000 PS I think which is a big
deal for us yes and as soon as this
happened everybody started hitting us up
with messages and in the comments
section hey man revisit revisit so you
know it's only happened a few days ago
Jenni's collected as much new
information as she kid she could so
we're gonna go ahead worker talk about
the original Night Stalker and what we
got right and what we got wrong yeah and
guess what we mostly got that [ __ ] I
called it I called it and a lot of other
people did too so one just me a law
enforcement knew kind of what kind of
guys to look for they're ex-military
probably ex-police I was surprised that
he was actual cop at the time that he
had been a cop Yeah right I thought that
maybe he had some law-enforcement
training but usually these guys don't
have the discipline to remain police for
very long so I thought maybe maybe even
be something more along the lines that
maybe like a postman somebody's like
somebody like BTK dog catcher yes he was
a cop yeah but he got fired
yeah because eventually eventually
typically kind of guys that it takes to
be a serial killer they don't have the
self-control necessary to hold of law
enforcement career down you know it's
only a matter of time so he got fired
for stealing [ __ ] stealing dog repellent
off of his job dog repellent that he was
using basically to to commit its Christ
made it to commit his crimes yeah but
yeah so the interesting thing about this
was that so on the Wednesday after our
last show came out we were discussing
what we were going to do for the next
episode we had an idea of what we were
gonna do
we were kind of talking about it and
stuff like that and then I started
getting all these messages from all
these people because I hadn't been
watching the news because I'd been
working on some other stuff and people
were like did you see did you see they
caught the original Night Stalker and I
was like holy crap so I did go look that
up and so by the time Wednesday night
rolled around we said okay well people
been commenting that you guys should do
a revisit on the whole topic so that's
what we decided to do we trashed we
trashed the whole show that we had
planned all that news and all I said
we're going to use that the next time
well yeah I'll do that and this is
basically gonna be like an emergency
news broadcast this is the only time
we're being like super topical we
because it's too much trouble yeah but
so what I wanted to do with this I mean
I should say we're recording this two
days before I'm putting it up because
you know I like to have time to edit it
and work on it and work on the video and
stuff like that so it seems at this
point that I've got pretty much the most
up-to-date news nothing really new has
been posted in the last several hours
and I don't really think there's going
to be anything like really
earth-shattering until his next court
appearance which is not until May 14th
so as far as I know I mean you know
barring something crazy happening in the
next couple days I think we're pretty
much yeah up with all the [ __ ] yeah if
you didn't listen to the original show
go back and listen to it was ever showed
eight episode eight so it's early I was
a long time ago it's almost kind of
painful for me to listen to that show
because boy he sounds so uncomfortable
and so formal doing that damn show
compared to now and I'm vaping my ass
off during those days maybe I we had 200
maybe 100 super worried I wasn't really
taking anything seriously dragging off
my [ __ ] bait and shed many people to
complain about some kind of respirator
you know you know hey calling you Darth
Vader yeah you know man was trying to
quit smoking I did quit smoking haven't
smoked I did you know yeah we yeah we
quit more than two years ago oh yeah
using vaping and I've quit vaping now -
yeah you still do but you don't really
do it on how to do it as much and I
don't need it as much as I used to
psychological see it's funny because I
can't you
listened to our episode 8 show the
original yeah we did it again yeah we
were nailing him okay I was saying
things that was just spot-on all right
now but here's the deal what I was
saying probably was not special law
enforcement was thinking the same thing
Yeah right I knew that this guy's
ex-military when they talked about the
diamond knot I went that's naval yep
okay cuz army doesn't use that not
Army's gonna use what's called a Ranger
not was a bowling and a two half hitches
you know that was the ones that we used
a lot so diamond not seamen guys that
you know in the Navy they are not
masters you know it's part of their
training to learn all these damn knots
that's their traditions that's our
cultures so I was going this dude's it
this dudes probably and I say it right
there it says that's naval okay naval
background and then he's running around
in public with a weapon engaging victims
shooting them and I'm thinking this
guy's comfortable walking around in a
neighborhood at the daytime with a
weapon
all right the average person wouldn't
try that they would think they'd be
spotted but cops know that you can walk
around neighborhoods in America all day
long with a gun in your hand and no one
will see you
most people are not looking out their
windows well yeah why would they be cops
run around all the time with guns and
nobody even notices those cops cuz most
people are just looking at what's inside
their house they're not looking out
their windows yeah American American
windows have shades on on the shades are
usually drawn so they'll hear something
go pop and by the time they actually
look out it's over it has gone so that
led me to believe that this guy has some
kind of a law enforcement background
that he's comfortable walking around in
public with a weapon knowing that he
probably will can get away with it
well he did get away did get her a very
long time and then his discipline about
inserting himself and extracting himself
from the scene using silent vehicles
like bicycle this guy is very tactical
I'm saying this is military and law
enforcement training he's staging his
ambushes in pre-planned attacks he's
going into the houses first to set up
the crime scene so he can dominate it
and come back later and dominate it even
break into a house to unload all the
guns yeah to get the layout he would
leave ligatures there
leave weapons inside the house Eve
things there yep come back later that
night when the people were there and
take over like a takeover robbery yeah
well that's all military and and law
enforcement tactics yeah that's you know
it's the it's not so much the tactical
stuff it's the strategy it's the
philosophies behind the military and law
enforcement training is just to actually
dominate the theater you know if you're
gonna do this kind of stuff you have to
have total control the only way to get
that total control is to set it up
beforehand so you're going into a
situation that you know you know there's
no unknowns that's very unusual
the average criminal just doesn't think
that way you know they do it on the fly
and make it up as they go so I knew he'd
be military or law enforcement but I
never thought he would have I never
thought it would be a guy doing it as he
was a policeman yeah I didn't think a
dude that [ __ ] up could hold down a
police job I was wrong this guy here
though is a rare case there's no other
offender like quite like this not really
the closest I can think of off the top
of my head would have been be TK TK they
have a very similar personality profiles
when you were talking about the planning
and stuff like that here's something
that I read on BBC news today and I had
never really read this anywhere else the
very famous murder that he did of Brian
and Katie Missouri who he basically shot
in the street they were walking their
dog in their neighborhood there was a
confrontation the two of them tried to
run away from him he subsequently chased
them and shot them they died later on
what I didn't know was that he had been
stalking at least her for a long time
before that attack even I mean that was
seemed like a botched attack so I had
thought I had always got the impression
that it was just like a random attack
like he ran into mid street in the
street like they saw him so he's like oh
I better kill him but evidently Katie
maggiore she had been being stalked at
work for several months she said there
was like a weird guy in a blue
Volkswagen Beetle outside her work
staring at her she had gotten a bunch of
prank phone calls about your
I'm is coming and all this kind of stuff
so even that which seemed like just sort
of a random kind of thing that happened
apparently according to the BBC
she was also being stalked because that
was kind of his thing so you know before
we get too far into this if obviously
everybody in the world probably knows
this by now but this past Tuesday August
24th
police arrested Joseph James D'Angelo a
72 year old man pretty sure he is the
Golden State killer that's him also
known as the original Night Stalker also
known as the east area rapist or the
Visalia ransack er which was his first
name now it's kind of interesting too
and I want to get into it a little bit
later about how they caught him but
they're pretty sure this is the guy yeah
you still have to say allegedly because
you know he's not convicted yet but DNA
don't lie yeah pretty much now although
I should say that the the first time
they tried to do the DNA they actually
misidentified the guy yeah but the chain
of evidence now though right they got
him yeah this guy now okay what we said
on the original show that we got right
about him being a military guy about him
being a cop and stuff like that all that
correct I have to say the one thing that
surprised me the most about when they
finally caught him and the more we learn
about him and stuff like that it
surprised me the most that he was still
alive yeah or that he was running around
outside of prison also surprised me that
he was still [ __ ] living in the area
that he terrorized yeah 780 back on the
first show I was thinking that probably
he broke into the wrong person's house
and that guy got it and they were and
they were the psychological profile even
says right that's the end look out for
the lone male perpetrator broke into a
house and got killed right look for that
because that's probably what and that's
kind of what I thought it probably
happened about why he stopped another
thing I want a message in that old video
there be guys in the comments you know
call them [ __ ] I when I'm saying how
would that guy know well this I'm
ex-military all my buddies a lot of my
good buddies are ex-military or their
military
now some of them special forces as a
matter of fact Jenny ended up in a photo
shoot with a Special Forces friend of
mine that's right yeah
I grew up with guys that are crime-scene
investigators all right some of them
with backgrounds in that same guy owned
his own paramedic company now what he
does is he does crime scenes for a
living he owns a company that does it I
grew up with guys that are now like best
friends that are now you know state
policemen in several states so I know
these guys and we talk shop you know
anything confidential they say to me I
would never put it out on the outter in
the web okay and I don't know anything
ongoing and it's not like that
but when I give an opinion it's based
upon actual training all right and I've
read a lot of these books like the FBI
profiling I've read them and I know guys
like that - you know I know guys on the
other side of the law - and now they
think yeah I'm not a duck and Jenny
writes this stuff for a living but no
what I said was true and law enforcement
was thinking the same thing so you know
I wasn't alone in thinking what I was
thinking yeah and it's basically just
logic logic tactics and having an
awareness of what the battlefields like
and what the street is like and what
crime is like and what prison life is
like and what military life is like and
wait cops think and the support behind
law enforcement once you understand
those systems and the philosophies that
they go by all this [ __ ] starts making
lots of sense yeah but like I said you
know one thing that they did get wrong
they didn't really get it wrong
necessarily but they did think that
probably the guy would only stop when he
was killed or put in prison for
something else which is what they
thought happened when the last known
original nightstalker crime occurred in
1986 because after that he stopped yeah
which means that you know they arrested
him at his home in Citrus Heights
outside of Sacramento like I said some
of the original break-ins because he
started with robberies in the early 70s
and then proceeded to rapes and then
proceeded to murders yeah just evolved
into this right see some of the rapes
and robberies happened in Citrus
so this guy has been living he he moved
to the house where he was arrested in
1983 he's been living there this whole
time yeah what happened was you know he
was law enforcement so he was educated
and he actually had a bachelor's degree
in criminal justice right so he knew
everything about investigative
techniques and how to avoid coming under
investigation as long as there's no
investigation there's not never gonna be
any kind of indictment but he knew about
the arrival of DNA technology yeah so he
went underground he stopped because he
knew that his DNA was out there he knew
that they didn't have his sample to
compare it to but he figured it
eventually if he kept doing his thing
they would get his blood and be able to
compare it to all those that DNA he left
behind and the crime scenes yeah yeah
criminals you no matter how good they
are they cannot predict the future you
had no idea that DNA would happen or the
DNA technology yeah I'm about because
interestingly the same year that he
stopped 1986 yeah that was the year that
the very first criminal was convicted
using DNA evidence and that happened in
Leicester England yeah and it was a guy
the guy who was popped was Colin
pitchfork of all things he was done for
murdering two teenage girls one in 1983
in 1981 in 1986 and he is gone down in
history as the first guy convicted of a
murder using DNA and actually the DNA
profiling was actually developed by the
at the University of Leicester and well
this guy's sophisticated you know he's
intelligent he's a professional he sees
that conviction and go down and he sees
the idea of DNA and he see internalize
is that he goes oh this is this you
can't do what I'm doing anymore yeah
they're gonna catch me which to me that
kind of kills me because particularly in
his early days with his robberies and
particularly his rapes he almost seemed
like a compulsive killer because some of
the rapes like there were two of them in
a week so I find it shocking that he was
able to stop even though in 1986 he I
think he was about
forty years old so maybe he was getting
to a point where oh I'm getting to a
push out on it or something like that
but it does seem weird although BTK did
it too right I mean he's young you've
got 14 years before he got caught he got
bored also they start to kind of burnout
yeah you know and where they don't have
the same interest in it that they used
to have yeah Triana you know sometimes
they kind of pine away for the glory
days of back when they could rape a
[ __ ] you know I mean that's the way the
[ __ ] thought they did it yeah
but they just they just don't have this
Drive in them anymore I really think sex
drive has a lot to do with it Wow when
you're looking at this guy this dude's a
rage monster oh yeah
he thinks he is just the [ __ ] he's a
lord and King he has the ability to come
in your house take your [ __ ] take your
woman and kill you and leave and nothing
eat your own [ __ ] eat your food out of
the year drink your beer let me go your
beer up and leave like a king like an
emperor oh yeah
that's who he this guy wants to be so
does this rage that kind of drove him to
do all this stuff you know and he just
thought he was better than everybody
else but he was intelligent enough to
know that he couldn't get away with it
anymore so he stopped but it should be
noted that he was obviously still
thinking about the [ __ ] because in once
in the 90s and once as late as 2001 he
was still allegedly calling his former
rape victims and [ __ ] with them power
yeah like I think in 2001 he actually
called up one of the women he had raped
24 years prior yeah and said something
like remember how we played yeah well
this [ __ ] like that yeah this guy here
you know he's on a huge power trip yeah
I would said that the closest thing to
him would have been okay well here let
me go to another extreme on the opposite
end of this spectrum would be Gary
Ridgway right look at Gary Ridgway just
a weaselly little wimp cowering before
the police during is questioning you
know I mean this dude's just like a zero
a total zero then you move up a little
bit you have BTK BTK is kind of an
intelligent guy he actually could become
a dog catcher but he was always a
wannabe he could never be a policeman he
couldn't cut that mustard this dude here
was the real deal he was a cop he could
be a cop for a certain amount of time
but his you
pull towards evil I guess that'd be a
good way to describe it got him into
trouble he lost his job well he's gonna
have like these feelings of resentment
against society mankind at large he's
too big for them he's better than them
they're taking things away from him you
know they're taking his job away and you
know that's what's driving him this
quest for vengeance you know vengeance
and dominance over others he's trying to
be a god on earth like a demonic force
that's how you dealing with yeah and
like I said I mean all this stuff about
him being disciplined and stuff like
that yeah we did say was in the Navy he
actually served he was in the Vietnam
War he served on the USS Canberra and
after he got out when he was about 27
then he like I said he had a degree in
criminal justice he was a cop in Exeter
California for three years and then he
moved to Auburn California and got a job
as a cop there and served there for
another three years until like you said
he either quit or got fired because he
was stealing [ __ ] he was stealing stuff
as Patton Oswalt put it stealing stuff
from the murder store yeah dog repellent
and like twine whatever it was well he
started getting off into this damn power
trip this godlike power trip where he
could just run around and kill and steal
and take it whatever he wanted just by
the power of his own authority judge
jury and executioner he does what he
wants well you could trouble thinking
like that yeah I mean even a lot of his
original a lot of the crime scenes where
he would do [ __ ] like you know he would
tie up the man and the woman he would
put the dishes on the man's back if I
hear these rattling while I'm raping
your wife yeah kill her I'm gonna kill
you and all this other kind of [ __ ] so
he really got off on just lording it
over other people having complete
control over them he would hang out in
their house and be really quiet for a
very long time so they would think that
he left right and then he would like pop
back out Adam [ __ ] like that well why be
a cop because what would you if when
you're a cop your power is limited yeah
you know you have a badge or a shield
jumped on a whole legal system that you
have to support people watching over you
but if you're one of these guys you can
just do whatever you want your judge
jury executioner yeah you
to worry about justice or right and
wrong you're gonna trans and evil you
just gonna be evil do it everyone that's
that's what this guy's getting off into
this you know this is kind of like some
kind of weird drug or an aphrodisiac for
him you know I mean being a cop would be
a step down in his mind yeah yeah now I
have to do what they want yeah you know
this guy's super super narcissistic they
said that his victims said that he would
lord over them and you know be superior
yeah power tripping power tripping
bigger and [ __ ] yeah the interesting
thing about it they haven't got a lot of
well so far they haven't got a lot of
comment from people that knew him on the
police force one guy that did work with
him in Exeter I believe did say that
they didn't really think anything of him
they didn't think he was strange um they
did say that he was very serious like he
couldn't really like relax or joke
around or oh just like that yeah kind of
uptight Oh
BTK yeah he was that similar type of
dude very regimented yeah now one very
interesting thing that one of the cops
said in 1975 there was a murder that is
not attributed to the original Night
Stalker it's not part of the you know
canonical 12 that they think were him
however they do think it's the same dude
they don't have they don't have proof of
it yet
but this happened when D'Angelo was a
cop and it was in the area where he
lived now this was during the area where
he it was still the Visalia ransac er
crimes I believe this was before the
first known rape yeah someone broke into
this house and tried to kidnap the 16
year old daughter right the girl's dad
Claude Snelling who was a journalism
professor he basically jumped on the
dude and tried to like save her right
and he got shot right and died now the
girl lived because then the the guy took
off but so even though Claude Snelling
is not generally you know is not yet
classed as an original Night Stalker
Golden State killer victim they think
that D'Angelo probably did that [ __ ] too
right and the interesting thing is that
now the cop that they talked to they
said I don't remember him investigating
murder directly but he would have been
here when we were investigating that
crime yeah and if he said the fact that
that guy was doing this [ __ ] and then
coming to work the next day and just
acting all normal super creepy like he's
like how can you do that well I'd have
to say just off the top of my head
that's probably one of the most
professional most organized serial
killers yeah I would say you know he's
an actual cop that's a high achiever for
a serial killer most serial killers are
losers they're overcompensating for a
bunch of other and AD inadequacies yeah
he had inadequacies but he could also
deliver he could make it on a police
force yeah that's that's saying a lot
you know you have to grade these guys
kind of on a curve right you know he was
a rage monster he wasn't a cop what he
really was just something more like a
tribal warrior he was a dude that would
come and cannibalize you or cut your
head off and take your woman and steal
your [ __ ] which is what a tribal warrior
does you're just doing it in the modern
world you know with a modern face a good
a good example of what I'm talking about
you guys have seen Hannibal rising and
Hannibal rising Hannibal is actually
kind of equated to a Japanese tribal
warrior or a samurai in a way if you see
the movie you'll see what I'm talking
about somebody that cuts somebody's head
off for money or even for dominance but
that's the way these guys are they are
primitive they're they're tapping into
primitive sources like I hate to to
describe them in those terms because I
don't like to you because I think that's
what they want they want to be glorified
because it should be noted that this guy
also had a lot of inadequacies that he
was overcompensating for according to
the large majority of his great victims
he had a quite a small penis through
some of his other rape victims reported
that he would cry yeah or he would say
things about his mother or about a woman
named Bonnie who I believe was an
ex-girlfriend that they were engaged and
she had dumped him and things like that
so well don't make any mistake I'm not
saying he's a great man I would see I do
was a [ __ ] some like like a tribal
rage monster yeah he was like you know
in another era era he would have been
maybe some tribalistic cannibal that
would come and cut your head off and
kill your woman too you know
something like that but he's doing it in
the model of modern era you know hating
another tribe yeah he's seeing everyone
else has another tribe in a way you know
that he's the leader of his own tribe
even though it's just him waging war
against mankind he hates humans you know
yeah you have to hate humans to do this
you know which again and that's another
thing that's weird because if you go on
the Golden State Killer Wikipedia page
which had which was updated almost
immediately so you know hey go whoever
did that like the very day he got caught
they'd updated it but it has the
original physical and psychological
profile from that the police put out
before you know he was caught and one of
the things that they said was that one
he he hated women particularly because
there was a lot of that kind of [ __ ] and
his you know that he said to his rape
victims and also that they didn't think
that he would have married or had a
family however that is incorrect he did
he did marry he married a woman named a
her name was Sharon huddle I think her
net last name was she was actually a
lawyer although they married in 1973
right some sources say that they
divorced some said that they were still
married technically but estranged I
don't think she'd had any particular
contact with him for a very long time
they actually had three daughters and
the daughters are now grown one of the
daughters was actually an ER doctor one
of them was a graduate student I don't
know what the other one did now when
they arrested him on April 24th one of
his daughters who was 36 years old was
living in the house with him along with
her 17 year old daughter now the shitty
thing is that now these two women are
going to be forever plagued I mean
they're never gonna mean I would change
my name if I was then right because how
are they ever gonna live a normal life
now because now the media is just gonna
be like you know barking down their
snorkel like trying to get [ __ ] about it
might settle down over time I hope it
will because I mean I just can't imagine
what it would be like to just be living
with your grandpa like a 17-year old a
normal teenage girl living with your
grandpa and
one day the cops show up and go oh by
the way he's a serial killer and rapist
okay probably ought to do now is to
probably take a break and we come back
listen this let's wrap some things up
and answer some questions and things
that yeah because I want to talk about a
little bit about the family I have a few
questions too okay all right so we're
gonna take a break right now we'll move
back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay we're back now I had had a question
was it ever resolved the tattoo on him
was it a bull or a bulldog because I
don't know this is one of the drawings I
saw of a depiction of him in a mask yeah
had the tattoo on his forearm and it was
a bulldog right other people that are
way into this case a no no no it was a
bull and it's a type of a bull
associated with the italian-american
community which that would have been
spot on because he is italian-american
but yeah by abide by the name so you
don't know yeah I'm not it's nothing
that I've seen lately as mentioned
anything about the tattoo on what I bet
she had that tattoo covered up maybe he
did yeah I didn't get a good enough look
like I saw there's some news footage of
him being wheeled into the courtroom in
a wheelchair for heaven's sakes
yeah but I didn't really get enough good
enough look at his arm tonight see about
the wheelchair think some people are
saying well he's faking that he's weak
behind the courthouse there's a bunch of
big cells where they keep the defendants
in there each courtroom has its own big
cell there's usually not enough room for
those guys to actually sit down so they
stand up and it's hard concrete floors
depending on what kind of shoes he was
taken in with that could have been
hurting his feet which meant that they
maybe would wheel him out on a on a
wheelchair the old to get broken down
pretty quickly in prison they ended up
sent him to the infirmary mostly so you
know I don't know if he was actually
faking being weak just that might been
just a perception yeah I mean I'm kind
of thinking I don't know if he actually
had legit use of that or if it was just
a ploy to make a beautiful like a
sympathetic old man because here's the
thing he's supposed to be physically
active he was very physically active
when they his name
I mean cuz he's lived there for 20 odd
years so some of the people that live in
the neighborhood still like they you
know they've grown up there and they
knew him so you know they said he's
actually a very active he he had a boat
he would go fishing he had a motorcycle
he heard a mountain bike he worked in
his garage like he was building a table
evidently the day before they arrested
him you know when they arrested him he
was cooking a big roast and all this
other stuff so he's not feeble by any
means he's gonna get his ass whipped in
prison on two counts you know why raping
underage women yes one strike yeah 13
year old your other strike as a cop and
a dirty cop yeah he's [ __ ] yeah which
you know he probably should be yeah
honestly because like I said you know
yeah we're still using the word
allegedly yeah he hasn't been convicted
yet and stuff like that but really the
DNA match that's right okay this is how
did they catch him tell him how they
caught it so here's the thing and this
is crazy
okay for for a long time they didn't
even know that the original Night
Stalker and the east area rapist and the
visalia ransack er were the same guy
they didn't even know that until like
2001 some [ __ ] like that when they
matched up all the DNA profiles and I
think when we did our original show
about the about original Night Stalker
back on episode 8 I think the FBI had
just done or had you know done not that
long earlier you know a renewed push
they had new sketches of him they had
new you know they had the $50,000 reward
something like that for tips and then
there was the book by Michelle McNamara
the true crime writer called I'll be
gone in the dark she had been working on
it for many years it was about the
original Night Stalker she died
obviously in April 2016 before the book
was entirely finished I bet think it was
about three-quarters done so her husband
Patton Oswalt he kind of got everyone
together and got someone to finish it
for her and it was actually just
published a couple of months ago when
right to the bestseller list and stuff
like that so some people are saying that
the case being back in the media might
have helped because here's the thing
Joseph D'Angelo now keep in mind at some
stage they had like a date
of like 8,000 persons of interest for
these crimes
Joseph D'Angelo was not in that database
he wasn't a suspect he wasn't a suspect
and the fact that this happened so
suddenly is one of the things that kills
me about it now what ended up happening
was that they had been trying they
decided they were going to use DNA
because they had DNA from I believe
through four to six of the crime scenes
that was still you know left over from
the from the old days so they said well
what we're gonna do is we're gonna go to
an open source genealogy website and
we're going to make a profile and upload
this DNA profile and see what matches we
get yeah so that's what they did
now since this has happened there's been
a whole bunch of like freaking out about
oh my god privacy concerns and DNA and
stuff like that but it's not as simple
as that because one they didn't use one
of the major genealogy website they
didn't use ancestor ancestry.com or
23andme or any the big ones they used a
smaller open-source one which actually
does have you know some legalese at the
beginning it says you know your debt you
are uploading your DNA profile to an
open-source site anybody can look at it
including cops so you know if you don't
want it there take it down because you
know we're not anybody can use it so
basically what ended up happening was
they uploaded this DNA profile of the
Golden State killer and then waited for
a match but it had to be a partial match
obviously so we had to find a relative
right and then from the matches that
they got they had to triangulate back
and study all these family trees cuz
apparently they've been doing this for
quite a long time yeah
now one of the first times they did this
they actually misidentified a guy at
first he was in an Oregon nursing home
and they had gone up there and they got
his DNA profile and they took DNA from
him while he was in the nursing home and
at first they thought maybe it was him
but then they figured out that it wasn't
but then they got the hit off Joseph
D'Angelo but like I said they it was
like I think it was his
great-great-grandfather maybe it was
some kind of match like he had this
great-great-grandfather's other person
that was on the site and so then they
triangulated they said okay well it has
to be a person that is a particular age
probably someone that lives in this
particular area and they basically just
kind of whittled it down they had it
they had a handful of suspects and then
they whittled it down to him because he
was the right age and the right location
and everything like that and then they
staked out his house for six days I
believe and they were waiting for him to
throw something out that had DNA on it
because if you throw something out in
the garbage it's not yours anymore and
somebody can take it so they went they
got they didn't say what the object was
but they evidently took something out of
his garbage or something like that that
had his DNA on it
that was some cigarettes probably or
something like that and it was a match
now they did it a second time - yeah
just to make sure that it wasn't you
know a [ __ ] the first time and then it
was a match and then they went and
arrested him yeah so hopefully because
I'm thinking look if it was me
and I was working on pretty much more I
mean he's one of the most prolific
serial rapists and killers in US history
and you know it's been 40 years no one's
caught him he was like this big mystery
and everything like that something in if
it's me and I'm a guy working on the
case I would want to make pretty [ __ ]
sure that every T was crossed and every
eye was dotted before he was arrested so
I'm kind of thinking and from what
they're saying you know the the defense
his defense team and he was assigned a
public defender I don't imagine anyone
want to defend him but you know probably
they had to you know I said you know I'm
saying no one came or wanted to so you
know right you know the public defender
has to defend them to trial is gonna be
a joke but yeah and the thing is that
you know the only defense that he's
trying to use the you know the hinting
of it is that they're gonna say oh well
the DNA was obtained illegally which
doesn't mean it wasn't and it really
wasn't he's what 74 years old he - okay
death penalty is off the table
even if he gets the death penalty he'll
die of old age before it's implemented
for it - yeah
get all those appeals life-sentence like
Santa's ain't [ __ ] for him that's for
five years four years that's nothing so
he's beyond punishment really he's just
gonna spend the rest of his life in
prison right doesn't matter if he gets
in died hit there doesn't matter if he
gets convicted doesn't matter if he gets
a death penalty or life he's gonna spend
the rest of his life in there fighting
probably most like he was gonna do it
easy to do what BTK did all right
in exchange for a life sentence which is
only a few years really from his point
of view he's gonna get up there and give
a beautiful grandstanding confession and
tell the whole story and go down as a
you know another one of these legendary
serial killers which is what I was
encouraging him to do in the last video
I said what do you want to do man you
just want to languish and obscurity come
forth you know come forward and claim it
claim all those the street cred points
that you earn from all these crimes are
you committed cuz that's usually what
they want to do
BTK started talking again because he
wanted to get caught so he could cash in
on this Fame and so I could relive his
glory days before he went off into
obscurity that's what that was all about
and yeah and that's the thing like I'm
kind of torn about this because I really
want him to talk he's gonna talk you
know because one I want to know like how
the [ __ ] he could like just live in this
community how he's how did he stop why
did he stop you know I'm curious about
the reasons for that he's gonna talk
because he's old I got a few years left
yeah I spend those years talking yeah so
I do want him to talk but then in
another way I don't really want him to
have the fame I don't want him to become
one of these like sexy famous serial
killers because I think that's kind of
[ __ ] up let's [ __ ] that but that's
just what she yeah they got fans and
honestly it's like I would rather know
not so much why he did it yeah it's like
I know why he did it he's a [ __ ] but
you know what I mean everyone should
know the story yes that's what he has to
contribute to criminology if I knew
someone that was
victim if I was a victim myself you'd
learn another detail I would want to
know and you know maybe some of them
wouldn't and that's you know that's up
to them I would want to know I want to
know like what the deal with him was
what made him tick
yeah it like that and his store is gonna
end you know contributing to the
forensic psychologists argue about that
because like I said it's yeah you don't
want to glorify them you don't want them
being famous for being serial killers
and you know people remember their names
but not their victims names I understand
that that is shitty but you have to
understand them to prevent the ship from
happening again I'm being or to at least
know what you're looking for yeah the
reason that we can do serial killer
profiling now is because they have
interviewed so many of them that they
know how they work I'm convinced that
these guys are actually a dying species
it doesn't mean that I hope yeah I hope
that's true it does seem like that the
the modern world the advent of social
media and internet I think is actually
preventing the creation of most of these
guys then those that are created anyway
end up being caught by all this
high-technology stuff that's going
that's happening now and they're caught
earlier yeah where before so these guys
are a dying breed and the reason and I
think maybe the reason that some of them
are caught earlier is because of all the
profiling work and stuff like that
because you can identify these guys
earlier I think in the 70s and 80s
before there was DNA I mean look at how
many of them look how long how many of
them got away with it and so I'm still
gonna wave a stone cause OD AK or
anybody like that I mean this guy got
away with it for [ __ ] 40-something
years he's just been living a [ __ ]
but evil life if zodiac appeared now
today doing what he did back then he'd
be caught yeah you know you this is from
another era yeah and it's just getting
getting cleaned up now yeah I figured he
was dead actually I did too I thought
that's why I was so shocked that they
said yeah they found him and he's just
live in a totally normal life with his
daughter and granddaughter right in the
same [ __ ] neighborhood where he used
to rape people yeah I figured he got
killed breaking into somebody's house
that's that's what I would have intended
I thought that if they had killed him as
an intruder the police would have
identified who he was and that didn't
happen
so I thought the other possibility was
is that he got killed during a break-in
the people that killed him - who exactly
who he was did something illegal to him
and didn't wanna you know I mean didn't
want to have to pay might have talked
about that on our original show and he
ended up wrapped up in chicken wire at
the bottom of the dam by you you know he
alligator food today I made him into
stew and yes something like that that's
right that's what there's always a
bigger fish and he was terrorizing
neighborhoods they knew that this guy
was out there so all these guys with
these good-looking wives if there was
any man and then would have started to
have these backup plans I'm gonna stash
a pistol here a lot of things that do
that right and I'm gonna I'm gonna be
ready for this guy when he comes in yeah
they had a LARP they'd like rod bells
all over all the windows right like they
had I saw one woman talking about when
she was a kid how her mom like would
sleep with an icepick under the pillow
and her dad missed a lot of the pillow
right so I think it was only a matter of
time before he got popped if ice already
yeah yeah something says you know
somebody oh look he's been in here I'm
okay I'm like he's coming tonight yeah
yeah no I'm gonna get him but I was
gonna say when we were talking about you
know him wanting to talk and wanting the
notoriety and stuff like that he really
does seem to me to be that kind of
personality and has been the whole
entire time oh man this is all about ego
yeah all of the like he he was one of
the same same type of guy as zodiac
where he's always like taunting the
police you know you dumb [ __ ] can't
catch me calling his victims sometimes
months years later you know and taunting
them reminding them about it [ __ ] like
that yeah so this is a guy that has a
lot of anger and I kind of want to talk
about that too because about his
neighbor's talking about him and [ __ ]
like that because they had some
interesting [ __ ] to say about too but
he's definitely that type of guy that
would want to be known as that like you
know I'm this big bad badass everyone
was terrified of me you know it just
hope this person whole personality type
just suggests that he would be the type
of dude to do yeah that's what I was
saying earlier saying he'd be he's like
a tribal warrior
a modern world this is a one-man force
of hatred this this is who you're
dealing with
don't look at this as some kind of some
kind of weird high-minded thing that he
saw you know on some movie somewhere you
know oh well in that this is just hate
hate and rage and he enjoyed it you know
sometimes you can work yourself up into
a rage and it feels good
well that's what he was doing - he cost
a little bit - as like I said he kind of
goes from one extreme to another
all right he's kind of like a super rage
monster like you know calling and
taunting and all this other kind of
stuff but then you get [ __ ] we're like
at some point in the 70s when he was
doing the rapes
he calls like a like a helpline or
something like that and saying I don't
want to do this anymore help me but then
like in the next second he would get
angry and be like are you tracing this
call or you know he's almost kind of
like a bipolar yeah he's like a bipolar
god if he had this weird kind of thing
well what happens this you know you work
stuff up into rage and I guess then you
realize well I've gone too far I can't
what have I become
and then you said oh man I feel bad I
had a terrible life oh no [ __ ] that I'm
back because I mean something else
that's kind of indicative now here's the
thing he worked as a cop until 1979 when
he got you know when he got I don't
think he was arrested but he was just
fired for for stealing dogs for bail
between 1979 and the early 90s they're
not real sure like he did live in that
same house as far as I know from the 80s
until then but they didn't know what he
did for work in that time not yet not
that it's come out anyways mechanically
well now and that was all in the early
90s
all right he got a job for I think it's
called save more or save a lot or so not
wasn't save a lot of a save more but it
was a like a grocery store chain okay he
worked at the distribution center in
Roseville as a mechanic he worked there
for 27 years he had just retired the
year before and he got arrested he's
retired last year and they talked to one
of his co-workers or his manager or
something like that and they said that
they just
no idea there like that that he had been
up to all that prior to I would imagine
that he stopped yeah he lost his
position as a cop so that meant that he
couldn't travel the streets freely and
start casing joints without attracting a
bunch of attention and DNA happened so
he knew that he had DNA out there
haunting him so he stopped laid low and
probably couldn't really sleep too well
at night for years he's probably worried
that they were gonna get him in any
minute
yeah because he lost the ability to
access his case and the progress of his
case because he lost his job yeah so
probably hungover me worried a lot man
you how could you sleep at night
committing all those crimes unless
you're a complete and utter no
Psychopaths well I don't
there's also self-preservation yeah he
had all those crimes out there he had
that DNA out there and he had no idea
whether or not they were coming for him
so that probably worried him for a long
did know I'm sure and then he tried to
get back to living kind of normal life
like I said you know working and but he
had a family which his family already
had family responsibilities so imagine
he spent a lot of time worrying yeah
about that [ __ ] probably think you know
sometimes in the 2000s he realized it
well they probably would have come for
me by now by now yeah and I probably got
off scot-free yeah so I'm just gonna
disappear like it never happened
but then evidently he be is backyard
Rajon and yelling and because you know
he's probably trying to recapture those
glory years I used to be able to do
whatever I want
yeah I used to be able to take a [ __ ]
take a person's [ __ ] [ __ ] take their
women and do whatever I wanted that was
the good old days yeah that's probably
exactly oh yeah I'm sure that's exactly
who I am he's one of those yes oh yeah I
can imagine that's probably exactly what
he was going through his head here's a
here's a detail to bother me so remember
I said that he would like in the 90s I
think it was 94 and he called one of his
former rape victims and was taunting her
this woman said she heard a woman's
voice and a kid's voice in the
background he's calling it on rape
victims his [ __ ] family in his
background what a [ __ ] oh well yes was
wife pride dressed him down on
you know yo yeah watch this you know
thinking them silly [ __ ] you [ __ ] I
hate I will do whatever I want to you
did not that's right yes right now oh I
feel that better yeah it was probably
those guys like that next I'm still I'm
still the original Night Stalker
yeah I'm still the original nice right
yeah and now some of his neighbors like
I said he had lived in this Citrus
Heights neighborhood block since 1983 so
a lot of people had grown up knowing him
like a lot of people that still lived
around there and knew who he was so
obviously they didn't know he was a
serial killer but a lot of them said the
same kind of thing they said super super
meticulous they said he was one of those
dudes just like BTK yeah they must hit
and my stepdad like your stepdad where
the grass had to be like all the same
level he was like yeah you know
retentive yeah they said he even had
permanent marks on his driveway where he
would park his boat cuz he had to park
the boat in exactly the same spot
everyone you see that the world will end
if you don't work it in the same there's
a lot of guys out there like that my
stepdad was one of them alright I've
done some people like this ya know most
of these guys are not killers thankfully
because I know a lot of people like that
they're just asked if they were all oh
yeah they're gonna tell you that while
they're gonna freak out over how you
coil up a hose right we're handed an
underhand it over and [ __ ] like a man
[ __ ] your hose dudes like that you know
that's not how you do this yeah well
show me how to do it you look at me look
at how they do it you can man your foot
that's exactly the same type of dude
this is and there's it's always a
wannabe type mentality in a way they
want to be you know meticulous and
military and this and that and the way
that they do things but they're not
soldiers they could never make it as a
soldier but they sure can coil a [ __ ]
hose well maybe bounces that and I think
you kind of had a really good insight
about this it's like these are guys that
are they're not failures necessarily are
losers in the same way that you know
some of the other serial killers are
they just like couldn't hold a job and
they realize
they have had some success like just the
ocher yeah he did he graduated from
college he was in the Navy he was a cop
and stuff like that so he wasn't a
failure but he wasn't great he wasn't as
great as they wanted as he wanted to be
yeah so his ambition way out raid like
what he actually accomplished and he
probably felt inadequate because of that
I'm a mechanic I'm okay mechanic I'm not
a great mechanic
so northern order to compensate I'm
gonna show you how to coil a hose right
in a way that only an expert mechanic
would boil a [ __ ] arrow so brings
back memories I am taking [ __ ] your hose
I will cut your hose because they can't
succeed the way they want to or they
can't succeed and important things yeah
then they get all high and mighty about
little little [ __ ] doesn't nobody cares
no one cares about it and they get like
really anal retentive about it like I
said just like BTK now it should be
noted to that people that have lived
around D'Angelo for the past 20 odd
years since he's lived in this house a
couple of them called him freak they
said he wasn't
they said he was just like real rayji
like sometimes he'd like run around in
his backyard like yelling at nobody like
having a temper tantrum a couple of them
said I don't know who I am they know who
I have you have the original
Nightstalker that he might have been
doing give him a [ __ ] cape and [ __ ]
mask a really girly one because I know
that would make him a B but we can make
fun of him now but that [ __ ] was
that dumb asses out there killing people
well yeah now we can make fun of yeah
yeah yeah oh man I knew the old man
anyway and that making fun of a guy who
brought a lot of misery to other people
but it's always funny cuz you know you
should he should be there should be
mocked so it's not it's always kind of
an insignificant guy but like I said
some of the neighbors said that he was
prone to he did prowl in people's
backyards who he was still doing that
show yeah that's
call her mama I said this guy's a
peeping tom he is a peeping tom yep he's
beavers yeah he did that said in the
first show he also in the 90s he called
and threatened to kill someone if they
didn't get their dogs stop barking and
actually it's funny because I'm on a
Golden State killer Facebook group so
some people that comment on their
ostensibly live in that area yeah and a
couple of them said that they knew him
or knew of him like they'd seen him
around the neighborhood like one guy
said oh I see this guy every morning he
rides his mountain bike you know the
same route as me one person on there
said that they'd worked as an auto tech
at the local Walmart and they said this
guy used to come in here all the time
and he was a dick and a half that's it
like BTK yeah they said he would always
like park illegally like if you tell him
about it he was like scream at you he
thought he was better than everyone yeah
so he's definitely that kind of dude but
really what he was was a peeping tom
that decided to go in there and get some
stuff and steal some stuff and while
he's there he's gonna steal some women
all right I'm gonna take that too and
then that guy and they challenged me
they said I only did it when the men
weren't around you know what no no no
I'm gonna do it when he's there too and
then eventually I'm gonna kill them all
and then I'm gonna eat all their stuff
I'm the greatest in the world I'm the
Great and then I'm not not gonna get
caught is was a highly-evolved peeping
tom who thought he was a commando and
used commando and police tactics to be a
peeping tom slash thief rapist murder
yeah that's all and like I said I she
has balls but you saw a piece of [ __ ]
yeah he said it was it he was addicted
to the debt the endorphins in the
adrenaline rush of doing these fake
commando mission slash raids on people's
houses to steal their [ __ ] that's
exactly their work yeah what they were
because I mean he did like I said he
would stake out like several houses in a
neighborhood for weeks or months ahead
of time until he could pick the best one
you know what I mean he would call
people ahead and see what their
schedules were so there was like a lot
of planning involved he's like I'm the
greatest [ __ ] commando that's ever been
around I must deal that [ __ ] [ __ ]
commands at his command oh yeah that
isn't that piece of [ __ ] that's a l'eau
you know for sex
doing it for sex sex and power yeah and
like I said I was
I'm kind of curious like I you know I
feel bad because you know I'm sure his
poor wife that they've been extranged
I'm sure she doesn't have anything to do
with and doesn't want anything to do
with it she has not commented at all
blame her but I'm kind of curious as to
what he was like what it was like being
married like did she know did she have
any suspicions it's he might not know I
think he might have threatened her every
now and then you know looking I'm more
than what you think I am you know
they're looking for me yeah did he beat
her because it seems like he's the type
of dude they would be he would be in in
that probe he would be it for sure
emotionally I mean he's one of those cuz
I will smack a [ __ ] you know that yeah
he definitely came across like this
probably so yeah I'm kind of like I said
I don't if she doesn't want to speak out
she shouldn't have to like I wouldn't
blame her I think that I kind of have a
tendency to think that he probably did
not molest his daughters I have a
feeling that he probably did not I bet
you he was ultra controlling and ultra
protective of them that's kind of what
I'm getting to I don't get I mean he did
rape a 13 year old girl yet what stage
but yeah I don't you ink because he's
the type of guy that would think these
are mine these are mine so I'm not gonna
do anything so I said you know do
anything I just tell yours yeah that's
what that that's me because I think that
he would have thought of them as people
but he doesn't didn't think of anyone
else Oh more like possessions his
possessions yeah but he's gonna keep his
possessions might act and I'm
respectable way so these are respectable
your [ __ ] is not respectable your [ __ ]
is mine and my [ __ ] is mine yeah that's
the mentality yeah that's exactly right
so yeah that's ID so I definitely don't
think that he was but I think he might
have been there's a possibility but I'm
just saying it's unlikely yeah I but I
definitely although smacking your wife
that's that's within the realm of this
is mine yeah that's his mind like I said
that was not shocked me if he willingly
as you get disciplined on you I'm making
you do the right thing that's the way
they [ __ ] do that [ __ ] now could be
that he was so manipulative that he
didn't have to use force just use me you
know my control mind control yeah but
the thing that I wanted to say about
this kind of enclosing is that so I'm
working on the second volume of the
faceless villain as most of you now yeah
oh yeah I listen
I almost said Jenny don't don't do that
do it do a book about about the original
original night
Sean McNamara already did one yeah just
came out yeah she said she said nah yeah
and I was besides yeah I got the trilogy
to do yeah and the thing is well when I
wrote the when I did the outline for
this second volume obviously most of the
original Nightstalker crimes are gonna
be in there okay
and I hadn't got to that part yet yeah
cuz I hadn't got to the 1975 or 1976
chapter yet so I hadn't written them and
then when he got caught I was totally
shocked and I was like well [ __ ] should
I leave the [ __ ] in there because you
know the books about unsolved crimes and
now apparently they're solved allegedly
like I said they're pretty pretty sure
that this is the guy I mean like I said
the DNA matches and at the moment he's
accused of he's up for eight counts of
murder they're trying to tie him to all
12 and possibly the 13th which is Claude
Snelling like I said because they think
that was the same they don't have DNA
from that but it's kind of the same MO
was in the same area the ones that they
had DNA evidence on he has been linked
to you know though they're gonna try and
get those indictments as well later on
so we'll see how that goes his next
court appearance is May 14th and I don't
know if there's gonna be any news before
that but I but anyway I decided that I
wasn't gonna put the original night
soccer crimes in the book after all
because like I said Michelle McNamara
the late Michelle McNamara already had
the book about it and it just came out
there's a big bestseller and it's
apparently very good I've read excerpts
of it and it's actually really
beautifully written so I'm just gonna
leave that alone
but I should say that I was completely
[ __ ] shocked that they and I think
they were shocked that they caught the
dude to just like because he wasn't even
on the radar and then all of a sudden
there he was actually I caught him you
caught yeah that last show I'm
encouraging it sounded cool thank you
yeah but get really cool if I can spend
to spin it in yeah I mean the reason
that it was so shocking is because if
one of his distant relatives he hadn't
happened to upload their DNA profile to
that particular genealogy say they never
would've they probably never would have
found it although this creepy that kind
of [ __ ] statistically probably happened
many times over the past 15 years where
something almost happened to get him
caught just happened
this one actually actually actually went
through so he was probably almost caught
many times yeah but it was there
anything else you've dug up any more
recent events on this case I don't think
so okay then I guess we can kind of wrap
it up this is our informal first
discussion of the capture of the
original Night Stalker and we were
vindicated a lot of the stuff you've got
is that they gotta you know leave it and
a lot of the stuff from our first show
proved to be true and like I said a lot
of a lot of the psychological profile
that they established before that turned
out to be fairly accurate are they yeah
I mean other than him being married and
other than him being yeah we gave our
pin we thought he'd be dead we gave our
something else about that we gave our
opinions on it we were mostly right and
it mostly lined up with what the other
people independently we're looking for
also yeah the the authorities we're
thinking the same thing we were thinking
yeah and we didn't do a huge amount of
research on that on that first show just
you know well just the regular guy
usually it was pretty obvious what kind
of guy it was to me it was yeah to you
it was - yeah yeah yeah they you know
these kind of guys fall into different
categories and like I said he was
similar to BTK similar kind of category
so like I said I can't believe I said
several okay I said several times this
is gonna be a guy kinda like BTK yeah
yeah and it was and that's exactly what
it was yeah so we're gonna have to keep
watching the news and see how this all
see much more comes out yeah well he's
now we'll keep everybody updated if
anything interesting comes out on the
case I believe he talks I really want
him to yeah will either put it in our
news reports or will do another
dedicated show yeah all right so we'll
wrap this up our like I said our
informal discussion about the capture of
the Golden State Killer aka the original
Night Stalker
which we did a episode about way back on
Episode eight ways when when we were a
new show what is such a fun we're almost
at 25 26 hundred subs now yeah so
growing fast please share like subscribe
comment and really and thanks for
everybody for giving me a heads up on
this story if we're asking for us to do
a revisit cuz I'm really glad we got to
do this and yeah we've had a lot of
requests for new stuff and we're working
on it all if it was
requested we've got it written down so
yeah it's like and yeah it's not it's
not a case of you know we're ignoring
your or anything like that but it's like
if you requested a movie for us to
review or if you requested a topic we
probably generally will get to it at
some point if it was a good reveal it
but I have you'd understand I have a
huge huge list like the movie review
list is like three columns long yeah and
Jenny's writing a book right now - so
she's writing a book she's running a
company she's running a graphic design
company she's do did the new record
album cover for starry night starry
night new packaging and stuff yeah you
know one is hired is what he said one of
these days we got a plug that healing
butterfly matcha tea that [ __ ] is so
good yeah I designed their practice we
get free samples the mint is my favorite
yeah but evidently the vanilla is the
vanilla and chocolate about selling
that's what I like I like the mint the
best and you really like the ginger team
I like the ginger and that will probably
be available in stores eventually but I
think they have online sales for right
now that's that stuff is really good
unfortunately we can't give any free
samples away or we would but Jenny did
the packaging and all the design on that
and we got all those free samples of it
no it was good it is very nice and they
have some new products that are coming
out that are even better I think right
but I can't tell you what but if any of
you guys buy that stuff do a review for
it please yeah that company actually
wants new reviews yeah because they're
changing the blends like that one flavor
that came out I didn't like it yeah what
was it chocolate one of them I didn't
like yeah you told me later on well they
changed it yeah cuz they're trying to
get the flavors right yeah on some of
the flavors yeah it's a small business
and they're from you know they're right
around here based in Florida where we
are and they're really cool people and
they're you know small business local
business and they make really really
nice stuff yes if you want some matcha
by some that healing butterfly matcha
Jani made that I made the package anyway
so anyway that'll do it for episode 89
remember to Like share subscribe on all
your social media share with all your
friends also if you'd like to
financially support the show which would
be very nice you can go to our patreon
page at patreon.com slash
Shiina clock podcast or if you'd like to
give a one-time PayPal donation you can
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcasts top wordpress.com and there's a
link in the sidebar to a PayPal account
where you can give a donation there if
you would like also check out our
dazzling calm / 13 o'clock we have
several different designs of t-shirts
and a tote bag that you may purchase
also if you haven't seen it yet we did a
really cool movie review of John
Carpenter's body bags a kind of
underrated John Carpenter movie and one
where I keep saying cuz you know I'm
always saying oh he didn't do any good
movies after the eighties blah blah blah
but actually I take that back because
this one was very good it's from 1993
and it's available on TV TV if you want
to watch it and our review of it just
went up a few days ago so go check that
out
and that will do it for this episode
we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]